un important projet de recherche est en
cours tout autour du lac saint-pierre ce
littoral c'est un véritable joyau mise à
mal par l'intensification des pratiques
agricoles
mais des chercheurs de concert avec des
agriculteurs tentent de développer des
modèles d'agriculture durable pour
protéger ce riche écosystème
ce grand bassin d'eau douce est l'une
des richesses aquatiques du québec créée
par un élargissement du fleuve saint
laurent
le lac saint pierre est d'ailleurs
désigné réserve mondiale de la biosphère
par l'unesco
son littoral abrite une biodiversité
exceptionnelle autour du lac
l'agriculture est omniprésente les
terres inondées chaque année sont très
riches mais la culture intensive du maïs
et du soya détériore la santé du lac et
menace la perchaude et le brochet
notamment ses cultures en principe
interdite en zone inondable sont tolérés
par les autorités
on cultive dans un environnement
aquatique
il faut en tenir compte concilier
agriculture et protection de cet
écosystème fragile devient un immense
défi
c'est le mandat qui a été confié à une
vingtaine de chercheurs de trois
universités québécoises
c'est de voir qu'un ce serait les
pratiques qu'on pourrait adapter à cette
situation
il s'agit d'un des plus vastes projets
de recherche jamais réalisée au québec
les scientifiques sont déployés sur le
terrain pendant trois ans leurs travaux
se déroulent dans quatre secteurs baie
du febvre et pierre ville sur la rive
sud saint barthélémy et la visitation de
l'île dupas sur la rive-nord les c'est à
l'étude sont variés ils vont du milieu
naturel à la monoculture intensive
et les agriculteurs sont mises à
contribution car la réussite de ce
projet repose en bonne partie sur leurs
épaules
[Musique]
à
les oies blanches font leur halte
printanière dans les champs de
baie-du-febvre inondé depuis quelques
semaines déjà
le site est en partie un milieu protégé
et une prairie agricole composé de
plantes fourragères et herbacées les
chercheurs il prépare une expédition en
kayak
en fait c'est habituel mais aussi
aujourd'hui on veut retirer le permis
dit m quant au mal pendant leurs
déplacements dans les champs les
étudiantes daphné et savannah font des
relevés avec une sonde
elle prélève aussi des échantillons
d'eau pour en évaluer la turbidité
c'est à dire le niveau de matières en
suspension un indicateur de la qualité
de l'eau l'échantillonnage permettra de
mesurer plus tard en laboratoire le type
de sédiments et de contaminants présents
comme les pesticides charriés par les
ruisseaux agricole
un drone suit de près toute l'opération
une culture beat it et 246 le phénomène
de turbidité au lac saint pierre est
complexe et la turbidité varient
beaucoup d'un endroit à l'autre
au printemps pendant les inondations
différentes masses d'eau se rencontrent
dans la plaine inondable
les eaux des rivières et ruisseaux
situés de part et d'autre des rives
l'eau du fleuve elles mêmes lots des
champs agricoles inondées
pour ajouter à la complexité la durée et
l'étendue des crues dans la plaine
inondable sont imprévisibles comme le
montre cette animation au printemps la
fonte des neiges fait gonfler le niveau
du lac saint pierre
il déborde alors à l'intérieur des
terres la zone inondée peut atteindre
des superficies impressionnante parfois
des dizaines de kilomètres carrés
ces images satellite montrent bien
l'ampleur de la grande inondation en
avril 2019
les taches brunes dans les zones
inondées sont dû à l'érosion et à la
forte quantité de sédiments dans l'eau
grâce aux mesures prises sur le terrain
les chercheurs développent un modèle de
l'écoulement et de la turbidité de l'eau
et la télédétection par laser permet de
calculer les niveaux d'eau en combinant
les images prises à partir du gronde à
l'imagerie satellitaire ils peuvent
localiser toutes ces données avec
précision sur l'ensemble du lac de
l'occupation du sol vont avoir un effet
jeté ma soeur les titans xuân à kliazma
chapitres sont voie mais il restera à
faire plus d'analystes pour quantifier
l'effet des patriotes et de l'occupation
du sol contre le projet alexandre roy
développe justement un algorithme pour
mieux comprendre l'évolution des niveaux
de turbidité dans l'histoire récente
il veut ainsi voir si les changements de
pratiques agricoles au fil des dernières
décennies ont fait grimper les niveaux
de turbidité 1984 dans la plaine
inondable évolué
sur un autre site de recherche de
baie-du-febvre la culture du soya en
semis direct sans couvert végétal a
laissé le sol près ce cas ni avec la
fonte des neiges le ruissellement
transporte des tonnes de sédiments
chargés de pesticides et d'engrais qui
bloque même parfois les tuyaux de
drainage l'absence de bandes riveraines
le long des terres agricoles accentue le
problème dans les ruisseaux agricole
hulot très turbide à la couleur du café
au lait toute cette publicité descend
dans la plaine inondable
elle rencontre le fleuve et le fleuve
remonter dans le plein pendant les crues
et là il se fait ce que j'appelle un
bouchon vaseux et donc cette jolie ce
fait elle est piégée dans les plaines
nolad au moment où les poissons ville
remonte pour se reproduire dos quittent
le noeud du problème il est l'abondance
de certains poissons à d'ailleurs
diminué au cours des dernières années
une baisse particulièrement dramatique
pour la perchaude espèce emblématique du
lac saint-pierre le bac puis on va
cumuler des poissons la population est
dans un état précaire malgré un
moratoire sur la pêche instaurée en 2012
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une perfo
d'olympe le sens revenus pour se nourrir
une relation gilbert cas bénins craint
pour la survie de la perchaude ces
étudiants pêche à la senne dans le champ
d'un producteur agricole toujours à baie
du febvre
le site inondé est en fait un pâturage
de plantes pérennes ou viendra se
nourrir plus tard le bétail les plantes
sous l'eau survival hiver la condition
physique des petites perchaude est bonne
d'abord parce que les tiges des plantes
retiennent les sédiments et réduisent la
turbidité de l'eau dans les années 80 il
y avait beaucoup plus de culture de foin
que maintenant et le foin joue ce rôle
là presque à merveille ses jeux dans
l'est c'est un peu dans la dernière
coupe
et puis donc historiquement la qualité
de l'eau de la plaine inondations
étaient grandement supérieure et
l'endroit est un garde-manger printanier
bien garni la perchaude trouve ici des
proies du zooplancton en abondance 100 à
200 fois plus que dans le lac le
zooplancton est constituée de petits
organismes qui peuvent survivre toute
l'année
quand le sol n'est pas labourer ou
laisser à nu un peu plus à l'ouest à
pierreville les chercheurs prélève les
plantes qui ont résisté à l'hiver et qui
émergent ils vont les rincer les faire
sécher et les pesées le but est de
comprendre dans quelle mesure les
différentes pratiques agricoles créer
des habitats favorables aux poissons et
laisse au printemps une bio masse une
structure végétale essentiels à la
reproduction du brochet et de la
perchaude il faut comprendre par exemple
que la perchaude ponder long chapelet
deux qui font plusieurs mètres de long
des rubans qui vont enrubanné la
végétation aussi a pas de végétation
résiduelles les oeufs vont tomber dans
la seule la boue si on veut et vont
manquer d'oxygène
on va avoir des problèmes de
développement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les chercheurs mettent le
cap sur la baie de maskinongé qui longe
l'autoroute 40 sur la rive nord du lac
saint pierre laforest d'érablières
argenté est encore inondée
ce milieu naturel est idéal pour la
reproduction de la perchaude on pourrait
décrire cela comme un peu la cadillac
des environnements pour le poisson au
lac saint pierre les décomptes de larves
de perchaudes et de brochets sont
d'ailleurs spectaculaire on a vu des
larmes de perchaudes qu'on avait et
échantillonné la semaine de passer mais
qui ont déjà organisé de façon
extraordinaire et on avait aussi des
petits brochets des bretons qui ont déjà
plusieurs centimètres de long
[Musique]
la baie de maskinongé regorge de
zooplancton de toutes les tailles et
l'eau contient très peu de matières
d'origine agricole selon les relevés
effectués par le chercheur françois
guillemette chimiques qu'on utilise en
laboratoire et à l'autre extrême on va
très bien et chery cole disons à nu ou
de maïs ou de soya la grande et herlings
qui ont aussi signature complètement
opposé donc la plus extrême
[Musique]
à peine quelques kilomètres plus loin à
l'embouchure de la rivière du loup les
filets remonter à la surface sont
presque vides
notez que dans la pêche est décevante le
site moins protégées que la baie de
maskinongé est soumis au grand vent et
aux vagues et la rivière du loup draine
un important bassin agricole
reproduction et croissance des poissons
sur méditer et qualité de l'eau
dynamique des masses d'eau toutes les
données recueillies par les
scientifiques permettront de mieux
comprendre et d'évaluer l'impact
environnemental des pratiques agricoles
actuelles dans la plaine inondable du
lac saint-pierre mais surtout d'ajuster
le tir avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
[Musique]
prêtant 2020 juniors joinville
s'aventure en terrain inconnu
le producteur de maïs et de soya va
innover dans une partie de ces chants
qui se trouve en zone inondable avec
l'agronome and vanasse il a juste le se
voir spécialisés qui lui a été prêtée
spécialement pour les travaux de
recherche
il va faire une culture qu'il n'a jamais
tenté auparavant de leurs j'ai embarqué
parce que takashi rôle y peut rien faire
et j'ai mon côté j'aime au talent fin et
j'ai monté à le voir comme ça au moins
après ce belge pourrait dès que j'ai
j'ai contribué junior joinville va se
mit deux rangs de ré gras une graminée
entre ses rangs maïs c'est ce qu'on
appelle une culture intercalaire alors
fera pas comme un petit tapis va
recouvrir le sol pour éviter que le sol
soit ni la chercheuse and vanasse va
ensuite comparé cette plantation au
chant témoin de maïs en cultures
conventionnelles juste à côté
elle s'attend à ce que le système
racinaire durée gras provoque une
activité biologique plus intense dans le
sol ça va améliorer la structure sol
diminue un peu la compaction améliore de
l'aération de sol améliorer la fertilité
bataille pour la ville mais oui c'est
plus intéressant pour nous ça nous
complique la vie est un porc aux sages
de plus comme qu'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui c'est leur épopée du cher
demain matin parce que je faisais mais
on peut s'améliorer
le producteur a aussi utiliser des
semences de maïs non traitées aux
insecticides pendant le mois suivant les
semis les pièges à pas sont inspectés
chaque semaine pour évaluer la présence
d'insectes nuisibles
anne vanasse espère démontrer que les
semences enrobées ne sont pas
nécessaires en zone inondable alors on
va regarder les verts fils le faire les
bars blain la mouche de semis donc en
fait c'est des insectes qui peuvent qui
pourrait attaquer le grès
ce conte c'est essentiel pour réduire le
rejet de sédiments d'azoté de phosphore
et de pesticides vers les fossés et les
cours d'eau ce sont surtout des bandes
riveraines bien implantés le long des
champs de maïs et de soya
mais c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
à cause la plaine inondable beaucoup de
grincements désert de propagande donc
c'est quand même assez dur d'établir des
bandes herbacée pérenne cette grande
plante fourragère l'alpiste aux roseaux
est idéal elle résiste à l'inondation
etc tige rigide servent d'abri à la
perchaude en période de reproduction
mais pour réussir cette bande riveraine
de 4 mètres de large et combattre les
mauvaises herbes et l'a fallu faire
preuve d'imagination et utiliser un
mélange avec du riz gras le temps que
l'alpiste aux roseaux soit bien établie
les bandes riveraines sont des refuge
faunique cruciaux pour les insectes
chanteurs comme les grillons et les
sauterelles en particulier mais aussi
pour les oiseaux nicheurs des
indicateurs kling de la qualité de
l'environnement
si l'on rajoute qu on continue raphaël
proulx installe des enregistreurs
automatisé dans les sites de recherche
pour voir si leur biodiversité évolue
selon les pratiques agricoles en place
on vise la période d'un matin pour les
oiseaux nicheurs puis on vise la période
de fin de journée début de soirée pour
les insectes chantants salle plus tard
dans l'été
ces appareils enregistrent pendant trois
minutes
chaque demi heure ils peuvent capter les
champs dans un rayon d'environ 100 m ça
nous permet d'enregistrer dans plusieurs
sites de façon simultanée et ensuite on
fait l'analyse des chiens au laboratoire
pour identifier les espèces etc sont
présents
des études ont déjà démontré que la
disparition des prairies provoque un
déclin chez les oiseaux nicheurs comme
le buteur d'amérique où la bécassine de
wilson mais raphaël proulx constate des
variations importantes dans les
populations d'oiseaux
dès que l'on modifie légèrement
l'utilisation du territoire
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus loin une autre
équipe se penchent spécifiquement sur
les insectes pollinisateurs
valérie fournier installe des bols bleu
blanc et jaune le long des bandes
riveraines
les vols sont ensuite rempli d'eau
savonneuse
alors pour les insectes c'est beau leur
présente comme une grosse fleur c'est
très attirant pour russes viennent se
déposer pourrait venir chercher du
nectar ou du pollen ça nous permet
ensuite de les dénombrer de jacques te
ment donc on veut ensuite les trier et
les épingler les identifier à l'espèce
la chercheuse s'intéresse
particulièrement aux abeilles sauvages
et à une famille de mouches les syrphes
qui sont de très bons pollinisateurs
elle veut évaluer si les nouvelles
pratiques agricoles mises à l'essai
améliore la bio diversité et l'abondance
de ces insectes la toute première année
le dénombrement des insectes a donné
lieu à des résultats surprenants
on a remarqué que dans les milieux
agricoles intense où la monoculture par
exemple de maïs par exemple il ya quand
même des pollinisateurs en plus que ce
qu'on pensait parce que les bandes
riveraines les bordures des champs et
les bords des fossés regorge de fleurs
sauvages attirante pour les
pollinisateurs
donc quand il ya beaucoup de
pollinisateurs par exemple beaucoup
d'insectes aquatiques bien c'est ça
dénote qu'un milieu est en santé
la plaine inondable du lac saint pierre
a déjà été en bien meilleure santé
au milieu du 19e siècle les terres
étaient cultivées en foin et en
pâturages mais elles ont été
reconverties graduellement en production
de maïs et de soya remettre une partie
de ses champs en prairie serait l'idéal
sur le plan environnemental mais cette
culture est mal adaptée à la réalité
agricole d'aujourd'hui la qualité du
foin laisse à désirer c'est à la blague
mais tout le monde le dit le foin sans
la grenouille
donc quand on meurt en échange il ya des
grenouilles on est en zone inondable
donc la première coupe de foin et pas
toujours peut-être de qualité
[Musique]
le producteur louis philippe dorin ville
soit amélioré ses performances sur le
plan environnemental
malgré toute sa bonne volonté il peut
difficilement se met autre chose que du
maïs et du soya dans ce champ inondé
presque chaque printemps sauvera faire
des fourrages en matant implante une
luzerne
ici on sera pas capable parce que avant
mourir au prêteur à défaut de cultiver
une plante fourragère ils s'aiment du
blé d'automne cette année entre ces
rentes soya quand les feuilles du soya
vont tomber l préserveront l'humidité du
sol et permettront aux blés de germer
une fois le seuil à récolter le blé va
proliférer et couvrir le sol en revient
au printemps pour voir si le blé
d'automne à puce survival a cru à la
fois pour retenir les sédiments et en
même temps ce serait intéressant de voir
est ce que la personne peut s'en servir
pour aller pondre ses oeufs dans dans ce
couvercle l'eau monte comme d'autres
producteurs de la région
louis-philippe de rainville n'a pas
hésité à s'impliquer dans les travaux de
recherche
même les producteurs on a fait partie
active des recherches on à faire des
assemblées pour trouver des solutions
des pistes de solution
cette ouverture au changement est aussi
motivée par autre chose
la politique québécoise de protection
des rives du littoral et des plaines
inondables interdit les activités
agricoles en zone littorale et le
règlement sur les exploitations
agricoles et le code de gestion des
pesticides interdisent l'épandage de
fertilisants et de pesticides dans les
cours d'eau où près de susi
jusqu'ici le ministère de
l'environnement tolère la situation et
en tirer de même les clans
agroenvironnementaux de fertilisation
des entreprises agricoles situées dans
la plaine inondable du lac saint pierre
mais l'étau se resserre on a commencé à
parler de lost importait faut respecter
nos batteries et bien comme il faut
ensuite il est venu un peu plus de
pression en disant que l'eau on n'a pas
le droit de cultiver foire était sûr je
dirais que plus ça vaut plus la pression
égard depuis oui on a une épée damoclès
au-dessus de la tête à tout les jours je
voudrais pas non plus arriver puisque
nous exemple le gouvernement ou
l'environnement nous disent d'aller vous
avez plus droit de cultiver votre été
quand même cédé ces détails qu'on a
acheté on a investi
parmi toutes les cultures qu'on essayait
mouallem paraît vraiment un successeur
les chercheurs explorent aussi le
potentiel d'espèces encore jamais
cultivé le long du littoral des espèces
capables de survivre aux inondations et
qui ont une courte saison de production
cette parcelle expérimentale de l'un par
exemple semble prometteuse vraiment le
lait nous aurait étonné à quel point il
l'a bien parti je dirais la levée était
très bonne même inconscience sécheresse
cette année on avait conscience s res
bien compétitionner mauvaises herbes et
le bien performé même dans les zones qui
étaient très inondés tournesol sarrazin
caméline pois haricots asclépiades
sureau sur la croissance rapide
une grande variété d'espèces sont à
l'essai tous les aspects de la
production sont étudiées la régie de
culture les coûts d'implantation les
rendements lee denner va se savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut diversifier
les cultures en termes de revenus mais
aussi peut-être un terme d'impact
environnemental
à l'évidence les agriculteurs devront
sortir de leur zone de confort pour un
producteur des enjeux ils sont à de
multiples niveaux
ils sont évidemment d'abord technique
parce que ça veut dire acquérir de
nouvelles expertises pour mettre en
place une pratique ils sont évidemment
du coût économique parce que souvent
changé sans à-coups nouvelle machinerie
spécialisée perte de superficies
cultivées nécessité de développer de
nouveaux marchés pour de nouvelles
cultures
la facture peut vite grimper mais les
nouvelles pratiques pourrait aussi
améliorer les rendements réduire les
applications de produits chimiques et
l'érosion des terres agricoles
l'enjeu en fait c'est pas de convaincre
mais c'est d'accompagner le changement
vraiment et cet accompagnement
il faut réussir à le faire à de
multiples niveaux faut le faire au
niveau de l'individu faut le faire au
niveau du collectif surtout du collectif
agricole
d'ailleurs les producteurs qui cultivent
dans la plaine inondable ne veulent pas
être les seuls à mettre l'épaule à la
roue
selon eux des pratiques durables doivent
être adoptés à l'échelle de tout le
bassin versant du lac saint pierre se
porte juste nous au je pense qu credo le
problème du lac-saint-pierre l'eau
viennent par tous
[Musique]
les travaux de recherche sont loin
d'être terminées mais il n'y aura
clairement pas de solution unique pour
restaurer la plaine inondable et
protéger le lac saint-pierre
donc on essaie de voir quels sont les
endroits qui ont une expression que non
utilisées qui serait laquelle il a
disons pour les poissons des endroits
qui sont être les meilleurs donc
peut-être qu'on doit prioriser certains
endroits pour restaurer et puis
maintenir l'agriculture ailleurs
[Musique]
maintenir l'enthousiasmé l'intérêt
risque aussi d'être tout un défi mais un
défi qu'il faudra relever pour espérer
protéger un des piliers du patrimoine
naturel au québec tous les grands
fleuves du monde ont des plaines
inondables qui sont assez majeurs qui
ont été transformés au fils des années
et partout où il se pose la même
question à savoir commun maintenant elle
devrait réhabiliter ces secteurs là où
comment il devrait aménager pour que ça
soit durable aussi harmonieuse vaut la
cohabitation fond du mans
[Musique]